[Musique]
bonjour bonjour
laissez moi tout de suite si vous me le
permettez commencer par les questions
existentielles waleffe à être rule the
world
l'art peut-il sauver l'économie
bonne question un délaissement
aujourd'hui vous dire yes et ken et
wheeler peut-être un vecteur de main
économique majeure oui des entrepreneurs
culturels
ça existe oui l'art et la culture
contribue à générer de la valeur
économique pour nos sociétés
mais c'est sûr que si vous demandez un
banquier réseau vous dire mais voyons
dont vous savez très bien qu'il n'ya pas
beaucoup d'argent dans l'armée civet
c'est sûr que le doute déjà entendu des
gens nous dire ah j'aimerais tellement
ça travailler dans l'armée tu sais je ne
ferai jamais d'argent philippa jeu je
préférerais plutôt me trouve un vrai
travail
et bien aujourd'hui pour tous ces gens
qui ont besoin d'être convaincus que bel
et bien de l'argent en or voici quelques
statistiques de notre très cher
gouvernement du canada en 2014
statistique canada a recensé d impact
économique direct de 50 4 milliards 600
millions de dollars pour le canada
ça c'est plus que le secteur de
l'hébergement et de la restauration et
c'est plus que le secteur de la chasse
de la pêche de la foresterie ca généré
au canada sept cent mille emplois la
culture en 2014 et ça c'est six fois
plus d'emplois que dans le secteur du
sport du cash en culture il y en a
est ce que je tenterai de vous dire que
tous les artistes roule dans les 20 de
l'heure à longueur de journée non non
non c'est vrai que gérer de l'argent
c'est pas le généralement la passion
numéro un des artistes genre je pense
pas que michelangelo pendant qui
peignait la chapelle sixtine penser à sa
facturation ti mais n'empêche que
michelangelo avait quand même le pape
comme client fait qu'ils devaient avoir
un certain sens du business mais quand
pas le vatican comme clients je compte
pas un doctorat honorifique pour remplir
une demande de subvention comment tu
fais pour commencer en tant qu'artiste
c'est un peu la question devait se poser
pendant que j'étudiais à l'uqam ici à
montréal puis avait pas que j'avais pas
mal d'amis artistes qui créent des
choses magnifiques mais qu'ils restaient
enfermés dans leur studio
c'est comme s'il y avait de la
difficulté à voir comment rejoindre un
public ou même commence en fait tout
simplement se trouver des acheteurs
et puis moi j'avais clairement pas le
budget d'ailleurs je vais toujours pas
d'acheter toutes leurs rêves et non plus
à produire toutes leurs idées spectacle
donc il fallait trouver une autre
solution
donc avec des amis on a démarré un
projet qu'on appelait chromatique qui
est un 360° sur la créativité et qui
montre vraiment l'effervescence
culturelle qu'on a ici à montréal on a
loué un endroit d affecter on a installé
des oeuvres de la lumière
on a invité quatre cents personnes qui
sont venues y avait de la bonne musique
tu es une vraie bonne soirée et on a
vendu 0 oeuvres d'art bon ben on a quand
même eu vraiment du fun et et on a quand
même pu amener beaucoup d'attention sur
les oeuvres jusqu'alors restée secrète
de nos amis artistes
donc on a continué on a continué on a
continué on a continué à un certain
moment donné il ya des représentants de
compagnies qui sont venus à nos
événements est tout de suite bien
entendus sont tombés sous le charme des
artistes et puis m'ont dit aux élèves se
sentent bon c'était peut-être 200 pièces
exactement mais j'étais très très très
content parce qu'on venait de trouver
une façon de rémunérer le travail de nos
amis artistes on est de comprendre que
relier les artistes les entreprises et
le public c'est un triangle qui était
gagnant pour tout le monde
les artistes gagnent en visibilité avec
avait des cachets d'artistes les
entreprises avait du contenu vraiment
unique pour leurs événements ou encore
leurs campagnes marketing et le public
avaient tout simplement accès à plus de
culture donc on ne réalise que c'est
assez rapidement que si on voulait
continuer à produire chromatique mais il
faudra bien qu'on se trouve une façon de
se financer à l'année on considère qu'on
pourrait offrir nos services aux
entreprises qui avaient besoin de
direction artistique ou de production
d'événements ou encore de contenu pour
leurs campagnes marketing ou même de
collection d'un rôdeur donc sept ans
plus tard avec cette offre de services
on a aidé 750 artistes à diffuser leurs
travaux dans plus de 11 villes avec 150
projets et 375 clients et partenaires
on ne réaliser que les entreprises
avaient besoin de beaucoup d'or on a
aussi réalisé que du jour au lendemain
on était devenus des vrais entrepreneurs
culturels on avait une vraie petite
business avec des bureaux des employés
des plantes des clientes les kits
mais bon maintenant ça c'est un peu la
version express parce qu'en réalité on
parle de sept ans de travail dont trois
bénévoles de beaucoup d'embûches et de
quand même une centaine de bénévoles
passionnés par la culture par les arts
qui m'ont appuyé dans ce processus là
c'est vrai que même si montréal est
reconnue comme étant une ville
culturelle de haut niveau partout dans
le monde
au début on ne savait pas toujours où se
tourner pour obtenir le soutien qu'on
avait besoin ou même trouver des clients
on allait aux organisations
développement économique de notre ville
qui nous faisait aux écoutes philippe
tomps projet est fantastique franchement
mais notre programme ne prend pas les
entreprises culturelles en compte
allez plutôt voir les conseillers des
arbres comme si la culture était pas un
développement économique comme les
autres et il nous est souvent d'aller
voir les conseils des arts puis encore à
ce moment là bas on avait un petit peu
difficulté entrée dans les programmes de
subventions publiques c'est comme son
fils est dangereux aucune cause donc à
un moment donné je lave ou ça m'arrivait
si peu jaloux de mes amis qui avaient
démarré des startups en teck
c'est il y avait des émissions télé des
anges investisseurs des programmes
spéciaux des hubs des espaces de
coworking ont même une région en
californie toi jose il ya quand même de
quoi être jaloux là j'ai fini par me
demander si ça existait un silicon
valley de la culture à ce que je ne sais
pas ça existe mais si on avait un enfer
un au canada clairement montréal serait
une ville championne pour la voir
montréal c'est la ville qui est le plus
la plus grande concentration d'artistes
au canada existe à montréal un espèce de
vague vraiment spécial les gens vraiment
unique autant au niveau des artistes que
des travers culturelle des entrepreneurs
culturels des mécènes des institutions
tous ces gens là ont des idées
fantastique souvent les méthodes de
travail qui sont absolument innovantes
mais le problème c'est qu'on les connaît
pas nécessairement donc avec la gagne 2
chromatique
on a démarré en mai dernier un nouveau
projet chromatique pro qui voulait
vraiment être un catalyseur pour
accélérer la croissance culturelle à
montréal
donc ce qu'on a fait c'est qu'on a
invité les artistes des entreprises des
entrepreneurs à mieux nous partager
leurs histoires nous partager leur
modèle d'affaires
pendant trois jours une 500 personnes
qui ont dû découvrir à travers des
conférences des workshops des ateliers
des séances de coaching du réseautage le
rôle de l'or dans les affaires et
l'entrepreneuriat république lui
découvrir l'amplitude finalement des
liens qu'ont fait créé entre on va faire
avec l'exemple d'autocad une entreprise
de logiciels 3d qui est basé à montréal
qui a ouvert récemment un studio
incroyable de résidence d'artiste à los
angeles ce qu'ils font ce qu'ils
jumelles des artistes avec les gens qui
sont responsables la recherche et
développement pour que les ingénieurs
puissent s'inspirer du processus créatif
des artistes assez rapidement avec les
projets fly et des artistes et on a
découvert des nouvelles limites au
logiciel et qui n'avait pas été soulevée
avant par autocar qui ont ensuite
développé des solutions qui ont été
vraiment utile au reste de l'industrie
donc on le voit bien les maillages à la
faire ça peut être vraiment gagnant mais
pas seulement pour
entreprise internationale on a aussi
voulu montrer avec chromatique troqué
fait tout à fait possible pour un
artiste de créer lui-même de la valeur
économique avec son propre corps qui
quoi de mieux qu'internet comme outils
pour le faire on a invité station 16 une
galerie montréalaise bien connu sur
internet à venir nous raconter comment
il avait réussi à exporter le travail de
panoplie d'artistes aux quatre coins du
globe mais bien l'histoire de stations
cesse c'est un artiste qui sait qui
voulait imprimer des 10 heures et qui a
rencontré un propriétaire d'une usine
d'impression et puis ensemble ils ont
trouvé le moyen de monter un réseau de
distribution et puis un million de
hashtag plus tard les voilà avec une
communauté de 28000 personnes qui
achètent religieusement des oeuvres
d'art de twitter de nos artistes
montréalais mais les impacts de la
culture ça s'arrête pas nécessairement
au domaine propre de la culture des fois
ça se répercute aussi sur des choses
aussi variées que l'immobilier sont
prend par exemple mile end à montréal
qui est un endroit qui veulent quelques
années a attiré beaucoup les artistes
pour en fait les coûts qui fait plutôt
bas pourrait donc des lieux parfaits
pour faire des studios de création au
fur et à mesure que les artistes
s'installent et y avait des cafés qui
ouvrait salle a amené les petites
boutiques salles a amené bon des
entrepreneurs à s'installer là bas
aujourd'hui à des multinationales dans
ce quartier là est clairement la valeur
économique immobilière secteur est
vraiment à la hausse
aujourd'hui notre défi si on veut
continuer afin que les artistes
développent la valeur de nos quartiers
se doter d'un mécanisme qui fait en
sorte que justement ils peuvent
continuer à se permettre des espaces de
travail abordable pour rester dans nos
quartiers et pas faire un exode hors des
centres villes
bref avec chromatique pro on a vraiment
voulu démontrer qu'ils jugeraient mille
et une façons de générer de la valeur
économique en mélangeant en ré affaire
puis on n'avait pas nécessairement
besoin d'être un mécène pour avoir un
impact sur la communauté artistique
locale on a aussi voulu faire en sorte
de rassembler tout le monde pour
qu'ensemble on puisse le créer
le silicon valley de la culture ici à
montréal
mais là bon vous allez vous dire ok ce
gars là ça fait dix minutes qui nous
parle de l'or qui va sauver l'économie
aujourd'hui j'aimerais ça vous dire
aussi exactement le contraire
lien existe des moments où l'art ne
participe aucunement au développement
économique
et c'est parfait comme ça le rôle des
fois de l'or ça se calcule pas toujours
en dollars ou en retombées économiques
directes des fois véhiculer des idées si
ça le rôle principal dehors et puis avec
les élections américaines de cette
semaine on peut dire que les artistes
ont pas mal de travail sur la flanc
gauche
et puis finalement cette capacité-là de
réflexion des artistes c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui est fondamental pour
nos sociétés
c'est pour ça que c'est extrêmement
important que nos conseils d or et nous
apparaît de soutien public de la culture
soient encouragés et bonifié à chaque
année mais bon
reste qu'un conseil des arts ça peut pas
tout faire et que c'est pour ça qu'avec
massivart depuis sept ans on essaie de
diversifier les revenus des artistes en
créant des ponts entre eux et les
entreprises et les marques
c'est entre et sept ans de recherche
extrêmement ce nom scientifique je puis
vous affirmer que les artistes et les
chefs d'entreprise ne parlent pas
toujours le même langage mais pourtant
elles sont extrêmement complémentaires
c'est aujourd'hui pour rester
compétitifs sur le marché international
il faut qu'il faut innover il faut être
créatif il faut briser le statu quo tu
des choses que les artistes font au
quotidien
aussi aujourd'hui on vit dans un monde
où on est assailli de contenu les
marques ont besoin de contenu plus que
jamais des photos des vidéos de la
musique toutes les choses qui sont
produites par les artistes on voit bien
il existe toujours un lieu où l'artiste
est capable de garder son intégrité
artistique et que la compagnie atteint
ses objectifs commerciaux
c'est le cas ici d'air d'un projet qu'on
a fait pour le restaurant de l'hôtel w à
montréal là restera it ou des artistes
ont été invités à créer absolument
librement des oeuvres qui aujourd'hui
participe vraiment au succès du
restaurant
c'est aussi le cas ici du quartier
l'innovation avec qui on a travaillé
récemment à implanter une signalétique
urbaine
ne pas jumeler des commerçants du
quartier avec des artistes qui ensemble
ont développé des sculptures qui ont
travaillé au sentiment d'appartenance
des commerçants au quartier tout en
développant une signalétique forte pour
ancrer ce quartier là dans le paysage
montréalais